(digital sounds)
- This look good?
- Yeah, yeah.
That's a real gun by
the way, so be careful.
- What?
- [Dennis] I said that's
a real gun, so be careful.
- You got a real gun?
- Well, it's my dad's.
- But why would you use a real gun?
This is a silly sketch.
- Because (laughs),
you see Black Rain?
- Jason] Black Rain?
- The movie.
- [Jason] With Michael Douglas?
- Yeah, see the guns,
how fake they looked?
- Just take this, I don't--
- [Sarah] Jay.
- Hey
- What're you doing?
What is this?
- What're you doing home?
I thought you were at work.
- Yeah I was.
Charlie had her check up remember?
Why are you wearing that ridiculous wig?
What, hi.
- [Jason] You know Dennis.
- Hi.
- We're shooting a video,
for a contest, for a comedy website.
- Alright, well what's the contest?
What's the prize?
- A tote bag.
(sighs)
- Jason I just saw this,
where you gonna tell me about this?
- I wanna pay that, I do.
You know right after this--
- You owe 30,000 dollars in back taxes?
- I know.
I saw that bill,
- I can't do this by myself anymore,
You have to get a job.
- I know, I gotta do something about that.
Gotta pay that.
I know.
You know I'm gonna get a job,
I'm gonna get a job,
right after we do this,
I'm gonna send out some emails.
- Okay (laughs)
You're gonna send out
some emails and get a job.
What're you gonna do, what's the plan?
- Look, I wanna reassure you that
totally responsible Jason is here,
and I'm going to grow up starting now.
- Shit, man.
This is loaded.
I forgot to take the clip out.
- Oh my God, Jason.
- You're not around a
lot of children, are you?
(upbeat rock music)